mes chers collègues nous poursuivons nos
travaux avec une table ronde sur la
perception des travaux à l'égard des
médias et de l'information dans le
contexte de la tenue des états généraux
du droit à l'information auquel j'ai
souhaité que notre Commission puisse
contribuer et donc je souhaite la
bienvenue en votre nom à tous à Monsieur
Bruno cotress chercheur au CNRS au
Centre de Recherche politique de
sciences pot donc que l'on connaît aussi
sous le nom de svof et de Monsieur
jean-diel Lévi directeur délégué de
Haris interactive France et de Madame
Laure salving directrice générale des
études de l'agence verille en France
donc monsieur cotress participera à nos
débats en visionférence depuis le Brésil
où il assure des enseignements au sein
de l'Université de Sao poo et il devra
donc nous quitter à 11h45 et je le
remercie d'avoir accepté de participer à
cette table ronde malgré un horaire
matinal de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
donc merci beaucoup je vous remercie
donc tous les trois de vous être rendu
disponible pour échanger avec les
membres de la commission sur une
problématique à laquelle les pouvoirs
publics cherchent des réponses depuis de
nombreuses années la défiance des
Français à l'égard des médias ce
phénomène déjà ancien semble
s'emplifieré et en février 2023 le
baromètre de la confiance politique du
cévipof montrait que seulement 28 % des
Français avaient très confiance ou
plutôt confiance dans les médias contre
69 % n'ayant plus plutôt pas confiance
ou pas du tout confiance en eux le
journal Lacroix et la verriant dans le
37e baromètre sur la confiance des
Français dans les médias arrivve à des
conclusions similaires 54 % des Français
pensent que la plupart du temps il faut
se méfier de ce que disent les médias
sur les grands sujets d'actualité contre
37 % qui pensent au contraire qu'on peut
en général leur faire confiance les
doutes sur l'impartialité et
l'indépendance des journalistes
constituent l'une des premières causes
de cette défiance à laquelle la loi du
24 novembre 2016 dite loi Bloche a
souhaité apporter des rép réponse
notamment en instaurant une obligation
pour les entreprises de presse d'adopter
une charte déontologique ou en créant
des comités d'éthique au sein des
services de radio ou de télévision et à
l'heure actuelle il y a une commission
d'évaluation de cette loi dont mon
collègue iniaki et Chanis et moi-même
sommes rapporteurs et nous avons
constaté au cours de nos travaux que les
deux obligations que je venais de de
mentionner étaient peu connues notamment
du du grand public et donc je voulais
savoir aussi comment analysez-vous
l'évolution de la confiance des franç
dans les médias outre le déficit supposé
d'indépendance et d'IMP d'impartialité
des journalistes quels sont les rapports
de la défiance quels sont les ressorts
de la
défiance je formulerai une hypothèse que
vous confirmerez ou affirmerez
n'observe-t-on pas un repli des Français
sur un nombre restreint de médias qui
conforte le lectorat dans ses
convictions ce phénomène n'alimente-t-il
pas la défiance à l'encontre des mauvais
médias c'est-à-dire ceux qui ne
partagent pas vos convictions et qui de
ce fait seraient forcément biaisé en
effet selon le baromètre 2023 de la
confiance des Français dans les médias
seulement 50 % d'entre eux déclarent se
faire leur opinion sur un sujet
d'actualité en confrontant ce que disent
plusieurs médias donc comment inciter
les Français à des comportements plus
pluralistes que nous apprennent les
comparaisons avec les pays de l'Union
européenne donc j'aurai encore beaucoup
d'autres questions mais je sais que mes
collègues en auront aussi et je vais
vous laisser la parole pour vos propos
liminires donc je vais reprendre euh
dans les ordres de parole ce que j'ai
énoncé au départ donc Monsieur cotress
Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE bonjour mesdames messieurs les
membres de la commission j'espère que
vous m'entendez bien ça va vous
m'entendez me voyez oui oui très très
bien parfait d'abord merci de
l'invitation c'est de très bon plaisir
pour moi
d'être particip à cette audition c'est
vrai qu'il est un peu un peu tôt pour
moi mais au fond il y a les mêmes
problèmes partout y compris au Brésil
hein de confiance dans les de confiance
dans les médias je vous rassure le le
premier point que je voudrais d'abord
dire en propos en propos méthodologique
un peu liminire il faut évidemment
situer la question de la confiance dans
les médias dans un ensemble un peu plus
large euh évidemment on peut pas
déconnecter la question de la confiance
dans les médias euh de la question plus
générale de la confiance dans l'ensemble
des acteurs euh du politique euh dans le
classement vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure notre enquête du svipof notre
baromètre de de confiance politique dont
la Nouvelle Vague paraîtra d'ailleurs
d'ici une dizaine de jours d'autres
enquêtes faites par d'autres instituts
et d'autres organisations vont dans le
même sens notre enquête montre toutes
les années que tout tout en bas du
classement des confiances des des
Français il y a tous les acteurs qui
concernent l'espace public la politique
qui s'agissent des partis politiques qui
s'agissent des médias euh qui s'agissent
bien évidemment du personnel politique
en en en règle générale et donc on peut
pas complètement décorréler la question
de la la confiance dans les médias de la
confiance plus générale dans la
politique et dans les acteurs du
politique voilà et c'est vrai que
euh les la confiance dans les médias est
plutôt au bas du classement vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure le le 28 % qui
éit plutôt un un chiffre plutôt haut en
fait nous avons eu au cours des 15
années d'existence de cette enquête nous
avons même connu des niveaux plus bas de
confiance dans les dans les dans dans
les médias euh comment expliquer euh
cette défiance quels en sont les quels
en sont les les ressorts nous on
travaille beaucoup sur cette question on
sait que euh la confiance c'est qu'un
mécanisme qui est un mécanisme qui
repose sur un un pari qu'on peut faire
sur les autres euh l'idée on va dire de
qu'on peut qu'on sera payé de retour de
sa confiance en gros c'est surtout ça
qui est le mécanisme le plus important
de la confiance et de la et de la
défiance et c'est vrai que les médias
ont une particularité
euh de ce point de vue là il leur est il
leur est difficile de renvoyer la balle
et de montrer que si on a confiance en
eux et bien ils vont être le lien va
être réciproque et c'est vrai que de ce
point de vue-là ce qui est absolument
capital et fondamental à mes yeux c'est
non seulement la question de la la la
pluralité bien évidemment mais ça c'est
c'est fondamental en en démocratie mais
c'est aussi la question de de dire
est-ce que est-ce que l'information qui
est qui est qui est donnée elle est bien
vérifiée est-ce que c'est une
information qui si elle a été pas assez
vérifiée si une information trompeuse a
été donnée est-ce que les médians ont
une capacité à reconnaître qu'ils se
sont qu'ils se sont trompés je pense que
ça c'est un point qui est assez je pense
que c'est un point qui est assez
important il y a peut-être aussi euh la
question l'autre question à mes yeux
assez assez fondamentale qui est la
question de l'éducation à regarder les
médias beaucoup de choses sont faites il
faut pas noircir le tableau beaucoup de
choses sont faites notre système
scolaire euh les acteurs de la société
civile tirent tous dans la même
direction et souhait tous onont éduquer
les citoyens à être de bons décodeurs de
l'information il y a beaucoup
d'initiatives qui sont qui sont qui sont
faites j'avais participé il y a quelques
mois à une rencontre qui était organisée
par la Ville de Paris qui est un peu sur
ces thèmes là qui m'a fait rencontrer de
très jeunes acteurs qui au niveau des
banlieux en particulier ont une très
grosse action pour former
éduquer les jeunes citoyens en
particulier à à être des des
auditeurs et des téléspectateurs
attentifs vigilants critiques et de leur
apprendre qu' a des qu' a des qu'il a
des outils vous en avez signalé un
absolument fondament la capacité à
mettre en perspective à comparer euh à
comparer les informations et au fond euh
c'est c'est d'ailleurs là un pilier je
pense du du journalisme et de
l'information la vérification des
sources bien évidemment il faut
apprendre aussi aux citoyens à devenir
un décodeur un vérificateur de source
beaucoup de choses sont faites euh si on
comparait la situation d'aujourd'hui à
celle d' a 20 30 40 ans on voit que des
métiers nouveaux sont apparus dans
l'espace médiatique euh les fact
checkers euh le journalisme basé sur des
données beaucoup de choses existent qui
n'existaient pas du tout à à à qui
n'existait pas du tout avant les les
grands médias de presse en particulier
se sont à peu près tous dotés maintenant
de cellules ou de ou de groupes de de
jeunes journalistes qui ont une bonne
formation à la question de de de
l'analyse empirique de l'analyse des
données je pense qu'il y a là un point
qui est qui est capital les les gens
comme moi mais je sais que les les
sondeurs qui son sont à vos côté vont
dans la même direction on a le même
objectif qui est de de de voir la la
capacité des des citoyens à lire la
formation à lire correctement les
données d'un sondage que que les médias
sachent le faire aussi euh voilà on voit
que beaucoup de choses ont été faites
beaucoup de choses restent à faire mais
voilà un enjeu qui me paraît capital et
bien évidemment le le chercheur et
l'enseignant universitaire que je suis
ne ne dira jamais qu'on perd son temps
en éduquant en formant et même si c'est
long même si c'est compliqué même si les
résultats ne sont pas là instantanément
on sait qu'on va dans la bonne direction
en faisant en faisant ça et je et je
pense en particulier à toutes ces
initiative qui existe he au niveau de en
particulier d'acteur de la société
civile donc voilà je pense que là c'est
c'est c'est c'est capital euh un un une
une grande chaîne de de radio nationale
le public à un à
à un slogan qui que que j'aime que
j'aime beaucoup il ils disent à propos
de même c'est pas juste l'information
mais l'info juste voilà et je pense que
là il y a vraiment un point qui est qui
est très très très important alors il y
a aussi la question et j'en finirai
peut-être par par là pour ce propos
liminire il y a peut-être aussi la
question euh bien évidemment du
pluralisme total dans les dans dans les
médias beaucoup ont le sentiment et euh
je dirais que de ce point de vue-là pas
participant moi-même fréquemment à des
émissions de commentaires politiques je
je bat ma coupe bien évidemment il y a
aussi parfois le sentiment qu'on voit
toujours les mêmes que ce sont toujours
les mêmes mots qui reviennent que ce
sont toujours les mêmes euh sujets qui
sont qui sont traités et il y a sans
doute beaucoup à faire sur la question
de la formation de l'agenda euh
médiatique beaucoup ont le sentiment que
on parle toujours des mêmes choses et
que il y a plein de problèmes qui sont
laissés de côté qui ne sont jamais
traités c'est pas seulement l'idée de
dire on parle que des trains qui
arrivent en retard on parle jamais des
trains qui sont qui sont qui sont qui
sont à l'heure c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que toute personne qui commente
l'actualité politique je je dois dire je
je trouve toute personne qui commente
l'actualité politique elle a un peu un
syndrome de de Cassandre on aime bien
les trucs qui vont pas bien on aime bien
quand il y a du drame on aime bien quand
les trains sont pas à l'heure et on
oublie souvent que beaucoup de choses
fonctionnent c'est pas seulement cette
idée de dire il faut aussi parler de ce
qui fonctionne de ce qui marche mais
c'est aussi l'idée que beaucoup de
sujets sont complètement mis de mis de
côté par exemple des sujets aussi
essentiels que la grande exclusion
sociale la pauvreté ne sont pratiquement
jamais traité il y a pratiquement jamais
un seul sujet au JT aux informations qui
sont données sur ces questionsl et par
contre on va revenir en boucle pendant
des mois pendant des mois des semaines
et des mois sur les mêmes sujet donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a peut-être aussi de
la part des citoyens qui regardent
parfois une forme de lassitude avec le
sentiment
que c'est toujours les mêmes sujets qui
sont traités par les mêmes personnes et
et qu'on est un peu en boucle sur des
sur des sujets pendant pendant des
semaines il y aura évidemment dans vos
réflexions j'imagine la question
d'accentuer le pluralisme même à
l'intérieur de de chaînes qui sont un
peu des chaînes niches et pourquoi pas
c'est c'est peut-êtrei aussi bien qu'il
y ait des des chaînes d'information ou
des canaux d'information qui servent des
publics très très segmentés mais mais si
on va dans cette direction la question
du pluralisme à l'intérieur de ces
segments devient quand même très
importante voilà donc quelques propos
liminires je ne sais pas si si j'ai
droit à davantage de temps ou il faut
peut-être que je que je cède la parole à
à à vos autres à vos autres
invités merci beaucoup oui effectivement
les autres invités vont pouvoir
s'exprimer mais c'est vrai que comme
vous partez à 11h45 vous n'aurez pas
l'occasion enfin vous aurez l'occasion
d'écouter une petite partie des
questions de des des collègues qui sont
dans la salle mais malheureusement vous
ne pourrez pas y répondre donc peut-être
qu'on pourra vous solliciter et voir des
échanges par écrit pour que l'échange
puisse se poursuivre puisque ces propos
liminires riches vont nécessairement
amener des questions mais maintenant je
passe la parole à Monsieur jean-diel
Levi il faut appuyer oui voilà merci
bonjour à toutes bonjour à tous euh je
suis un peu euh ennuyé parce que Bruno
cotess a dit beaucoup d'éléments que je
pensais euh que je pensais évoquer et et
notamment la la première mise en
perspective mais qui nous apparaît comme
étant absolument essentielle euh c'est
de d'essayer de de de se poser la
question est-ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui face à un enjeu qui touche
uniquement l'univers médiatique ou
est-ce que nous sommes plus face à un
enjeu qui est amené à toucher l'ensemble
des acteurs qui prennent la la parole
dans l'espace public et au regard des
différentes enquêtes qu'on peut être
amené à réaliser on voit bien qu'il y a
euh on va dire une suspicion initiale ou
une défiance à l'égard d'un acteur qui
est amené à prendre la parole dans
l'espace
public soit parce qu'il n'apparaît pas
comme étant
sincère soit parce que sous euh la
justification d'une forme d'expertise il
va faire valoir des opinions qui sont
propres soit parce qu'il pourrait y
avoir des intérêts cachés dans le cadre
de sa prise de parole donc ça touche
euh l'immense majorité des acteurs qui
prennent la parole dans l'espace public
et on voit bien dans les enquêtes que
nous somm amenés à réaliser qui sont des
enquêtes publiques comme des
enquêtes
confidentielles que le doute existe si
on jette la focale de manière un peu
plus
précise sur l'univers médiatique euh
nous avons été amenés au cours de la Pée
récente à réaliser justement une étude
dans le cadre des états généraux de
l'information euh qui m en avant un
certain nombre d'aspects euh le le le
premier
aspect c'est qu'il y a encore un intérêt
pour l'information euh ça n'est pas
forcément une évidence absolue euh il y
aura pu y avoir de la part de nos
compatriotes ou d'un certain nombre
d'entre eux l'idée de se dire je vais
vivre ma vie tranquillement et je n'ai
pas forcément besoin de savoir ce qui se
passe dans ma commune dans mon
département dans ma région en France ou
dans d'autres pays et qu'il y a encore
et toujours un intérêt qui est un
intérêt
manifeste nous le remarquons d'autant
plus que nous interrogeons de manière
spontanée toutes les semaines les
Français sur les sujets qui les ont
marqués on leur propose absolument rien
et nous
sommes à chaque fois surpris par la
richesse de la restitution qui peut être
faite de la part de nos compatriotes qui
ne va qui qui plus est pas forcément
évoquer la rubrique des chats écrasés ou
des fait divers mais qui peut même
mettre en avant des grands sujets qui
peutêtre des grands sujets
internationaux et avec même parfois une
forme de décorrélation
entre ce qui peut être identifié de la
part de nos concitoyens de ce qui les a
marqué dans l'actualité et la hiérarchie
à proprement parlé de l'information en
tout cas pour les grands médias
traditionnels installés au niveau
national je le dis assez souvent je le
répète ici les sujets internationaux ne
sont pas des points qui n'intéressent
pas nos compatriotes alors il les
intéressent de manière différente de la
structuration et du rapport qui pou
existé au cours des années 70 80 mais ce
qui a pu se passer en Syrie ce qui se
passe plus récemment euh en en Israël
euh la guerre euh entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine par exemple voir même parfois
le Yémen sont des sujets qui ressortent
spontanément de la part de nos
compatriotes alors même qu'ils ne sont
pas toujours considérés comme étant des
sujets qui vont susciter de l'audience
ou de l'intérêt de la part d'un certain
nombre de directions éditoriales dans
les grandes chaînes de de télévision et
de radio donc ça c'est peut-être le
premier volet il y a un intérêt qui est
qui est marqué
le deuxième aspect c'est que il y a une
forme d'interrogation qui là aussi ne
touche pas uniquement le l'univers du
journalisme concernant l'indépendance et
la
liberté l'indépendance et la liberté qui
d'ailleurs ne vont pas toucher que les
médias privés mais qui peuvent également
toucher les médias publics et à travers
l'enquête que nous avons été amenés à
réaliser dans le cadre de ces de ces
états généraux nous avons été frappés de
voir qu'il y avait un petit surplu de
confiance à l'égard des médias publics
mais que ça n'est pas un écart qui est
un écart habissal dans les
représentations et on peut voir d'un
point de vue global que on va avoir 4 5
6 points de plus de confiance à l'égard
de l'expression des médias publics par
rapport aux médias privés mais sans
qu'il y ait d'un côté des Français qui
vont dire ce qui relève du privé suscite
une défiance ce qui relève du public
suscite une forme de une forme de
confiance donc un intérêt pour
information un doute concernant
l'indépendance de la presse et la
liberté des journalistes et puis une
difficulté à
pouvoir tirer
euh une confiance également dans la
véracité de de l'information nous avons
par exemple 60 % des Français qui
déclarent qu'il leur arrive assez
fréquemment de rencontrer des
difficultés pour savoir si les
informations diffusées dans les médias
sont vraies ou fausses
et je Seris tenté de dire tout type de
médias confondu on pourra aller un peu
plus dans le détail tout à l'heure donc
on
a une un doute une interrogation sur
l'émetteur en tant que tel sur
l'indépendance qui peut exister qui peut
se traduire de différentes manières sur
la véracité des informations et même
avec une suspicion ou une interrogation
sur la volonté profonde de la part des
médias alors forcément c'est très
englobant de chercher et dans cette
quête de
vérité avec de manière sous-jacente le
doute n'y a-t-il pas aujourd'hui une
forme de course à l'audience qui ferait
que au nom de l'idée de se dire qu'on va
maximiser le dimat au nom de l'idée
qu'il va falloir tenir l'antenne au nom
de l'idée qu'il va falloir faire
l'événement qu'on va pas être
aujourd'hui d'une manière global dans
l'exposition de l'information de la mise
en l'avant de dimensions qui peuvent
apparaître comme étant spectaculaires
mais que celle-ci si elle ne serait pas
forcément complètement fausse pourrait
être tronquée ou pourrait mettre en
avant uniquement la dimension qui sera
la dimension la plus attirante ou en
tout cas la plus marquante sans
forcément entrer complètement dans le
vif du du
sujet le trisème type d'interrogation
que l'on peut avoir c'est y y a-t-il ou
pas une forme d'ancien monde qui
viendrait se confronter au Nouveau Monde
le nouveau monde étant les réseaux
sociaux ce qui est présent de manière
digital et numérique et face à cela des
médias un peu plus traditionnels
télévisuels et
radiophonique peut-être qu'en préalable
c'est pas une donnée d'enquête mais ce
sont des données Médiamétrie on peut
rappeler que nous avons près de 100
millions des Français qui regardent le
journal à 20h en France alors certes ça
n'est pas toute la population française
certes elle est assez clivée notamment
générationnellement mais que aujourd'hui
et on le voit bien d'ailleurs dans les
enquêtes par la suite que les plus
grands prescripteurs et les plus grands
entre guillemets influenceurs restent
encore le vinur des deux grandes chaînes
de télévision et que cette incidence est
une incidence assez importante et que
quand bien même il y aurait de la part
notamment des jeunes générations un
recours qui sera un recours massif euh à
des nouveaux médias entre guillemets que
sont Internet et les différents réseaux
sociaux il n'y a pas d'un côté même de
la part de ces jeunes générations une
confiance avérée à l'égard de ce qui
peut être dit sur les réseaux sociaux et
sur Internet qui viendrait supplanter
l'information ou la communication qui
pourrait être émise dans les grands
médias traditionnels donc il y a cette
forme de regard un peu global de
défiance à l'égard des différents
émetteurs et qui vient supplanter la
question du média ou du médium à à
proprement à proprement parler dans le
pays un peu défettiste qui a également
été évoqué tout à l'heure par par cot et
dans la perception que c'était mieux
avant qui traverse globalement la
société française les médias n'échappent
pas à cela même lorsqu'on interroge sur
la question ne serait-ce que de la
fiabilité de l'information nous avons
plus d'un Français sur de qui estime que
aujourd'hui les informations
apparaissent comme étant moins fiables
que par le passé la question de la
multiplication bien jouer également et
s'il doit y avoir des points qui sont
des points à leurs yeux qui pe être
rassurants c'est lorsqu'ils ont la
perception en confrontant une
information sur différents types de
médias que celle-ci étant indiquée de
manière diffuse celle-ci pourrait plutôt
être vrai vu qu'elle n'est pas émise par
un seul émetteur mais éventuellement par
plusieurs types d'émetteur ce qui peut
participer également du la croissance de
la
confiance c'est le fait que celle-ci
apparaisse comme étant neutre qu'il y a
des sources officielles qui sont
évoquées qu'elles sont également
corroboré par des données et par des
expertises scientifiques euh ceci n'est
pas non plus complètement une évidence
il y a parfois un doute à l'égard de ce
que peut être la parole scientifique à
proprement parler mais on l'a vu et je
pense que la période covid a été
également un élément qui a été un
élément supplémentaire d'appropriation
de la confiance qui pour être exprimée à
l'égard de la communauté scientifique un
point qui est un point de réassurance et
puis peut-être un dernier aspect qui est
un aspect positif et pour clôturer ce
cette première prise de parole et ouvrir
des des éléments de des éléments plutôt
positifs on a
aujourd'hui si ce n'est une défiance à
l'égard des
émetteurs une confiance qui nous a
apparu comme étant paradoxale à l'égard
des journalistes et qui vient
parfois déstabiliser par rapport à
d'autres enquêtes qui peuent être menées
d'un point de vue global nous
l'interprétons comme étant le fait que
il y a au jeu des Français une bonne
volonté individuelle de la part des
journalistes qu'il y a un travail qu'il
souhait faire mais que peut-être les
systèmes dans lesquels ils sont
aujourd'hui engagés les empêch les
limites de pouvoir mener globalement à
bien leur mission donc il ne semblent
pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain si
vous me permettez d'utiliser cette
expression et en se disant il y a
aujourd'hui la possibilité de pouvoir
avoir des renforts de confiance à
l'égard de l'information qui va reporer
sur une expertise scientifique qui va
reporter qui va reposer pardon sur des
dimensions de source et qui va également
reposer sur des personnes qui
intrinsèquement apparaissent comme étant
impliqué sincère si ce n'est qu'elles
sont parfois qu'ell rencontent parfois
des difficultés qui sont liées au cadre
environnant au sein duquel peuvent être
amené à
évoluer merci beaucoup monsieur Levi
excusez-moi pour pour ma carte de tout
qui à un moment vous a un peu perturbé
mais
c'était voilà c'est c'est les virus de
la saison qui sont passé par moi donc
madame salving je vous en
prie bonjour à toutes et à tous que lors
Salvin je je dirige l'institut de
sondage verriant qui est l'ancien
quantard public l'ancienne saoffrress
voilà pour par verian est tout nouveau
comme nom et donc effectivement nous
nous nous réalisons un baromètre de la
confiance des médias pour le journal
Lacroix deput de nombreuses années c'est
la 37e édition cette année que nous
venons de de de publier et ce qui m'a
marqué et je rejoindrai Bruno cotress et
et Jean-Daniel lit sur un certain nombre
de points ce qui me marque moi dans le
rapport aux médias aujourd'hui c'est que
finalement il n'a pas tant changé que ça
dans les 20 dernières années
c'est-à-dire que cette défiance à
l'égard des médias de l'institution
média finalement elle était déjà là
dans les années
90 dans les années 2000 donc premier
point on a toujours effectivement
l'impression que c'était mieux avant
mais en fait quand on compare les
données il y a 20 ans c'était la même
chose en tout cas le rapport de force
est est le même et le rapport de
défiance en l'occurrence est le même le
deuxième point je serais assez positive
aussi sur l'état de la société française
en matière de d'actualité et
d'information aussi euh dans notre
dernier baromètre justement 75 % des
Français nous disent qu'ils suivent avec
un grand intérêt l'actualité qui se
passe aujourd'hui en France et ça pour
moi c'est une bonne nouvelle à mettre en
avant peut-être davantage que
finalement d'autres d'autres éléments
pourquoi parce que ça veut dire que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre
sur les Français qui se désintéressent
de ce qui se passe dans la société
française qui se désintéresse du
collectif et cetera finalement on voit
quand même que l'information les
intéresse et d'ailleurs on le remarque
également sur l'actualité politique
normalement après une période
électorale l'intérêt pour l'actualité
politique redescend et là on remarque au
contraire en fait qu'elle n'a pas baissé
depuis depuis plus d'un an ça c'était
donc le le le le premier point le
deuxième point et je pense qu'on est
d'accord il y a un rapport vraiment très
paradoxal des Français à l'égard des
médias dès qu'on parle d'institution et
et là on peut le voir dans le cadre des
Eurobaromètres qu'on peut mener au
niveau européen quand on compare
effectivement la France par rapport aux
autres pays Européens on voit bien que
systématiquement la France a des avis
beaucoup plus négatifs sur tout ce qui
est institutionnel que le reste des
Européens pourquoi il y a plein de
raisons une des raisons c'est parce que
les Français attendent beaucoup aussi à
la fois et ça vous le savez de leurs
élus de
l'État mais aussi euh en matière de
grandes institutions qui représentent
quelque part euh la France donc cette
défiance générale effectivement elle
elle est bien là 57 % des Français
aujourd'hui se méfient de ce que disent
les médias on a aussi on a en a beaucoup
parlé une certaine
fatigue informationnelle et je crois que
ça c'est un des éléments clés de la
compréhension aussi du rapport aux
médias euh un petit peu plus de la
moitié des Français nous disent avoir
déjà ressenti de la fatigue
informationnelle et pourquoi c'est pas
par manque d'intérêt à nouveau ni par
manque d'utilité des informations qui
sont données mais il y a deux raisons
principales qui sont données par les
Français c'est un la redondance des
sujets traités ils ont effectivement
comme le disait Bruno cottrress le
sentiment que les mêmes sujets sont
traités de façon trop importante et
systématiquement les mêmes et donc dans
le dernier baromètre que que que vous
pourrez regarder on pose effectivement
une une question sur la perception des
sujets traités quels sont les sujets
qu'on a trop traité cette année donc en
2023 et ceux qu'on a pas suffisamment
traité il y a deux sujets que les
Français considèrent qu'on a trop traité
c'est le sujet de la mort de Naël et le
conflit en Ukraine et il y a trois
sujets que les Français considèrent
qu'on n pas suffisamment traité ce sont
les violences faites aux femmes les
difficultés rencontrées dans les
services publics et le sujet de la fin
de vie trois sujets qui effectivement
vont toucher au quotidien euh je dirais
et au cœur aussi des euh de la
communauté de la Communauté française
donc un on peut effectivement afficher à
la fois de la défiance ou une certaine
mise à l'écart mise à distance de la de
l'actualité à cause de cette redondance
perçue et puis le deuxième point
qu'évoque les Français c'est le
traitement des sujets un traitement
qu'il juge trop négatif et souvent trop
anxiogène et effectivement face à cette
actualité
euh
souvent du ils nous disent on on on se
sent complètement impuissant et c'est
peut-être là aussi où je rejoindrai
Bruno cotres qu'est-ce que le média va
m'envoyer en retour est-ce que je peux
faire quelque chose par rapport à cette
information qu'on me donne en fait les
Français se sonentent trop passifs c'est
trop violent et effectivement vont vont
vont vont vont de
fait mettre une certaine distance avec
ce qu'ils vont entendre ce qu'ils nous
disent par exemple c'est nous on
aimerait entendre par exemple sur le
sujet de l'environnement l'écologie
davantage de conseils pour pouvoir agir
en faveur de l'écologie en faveur de
l'environnement pas juste des
catastrophes mais donnez-nous des
conseils en fait et c'est peut-être là
aussi un des moyens de recréer la
confiance c'est de redonner du pouvoir
quelque part aux citoyens en tout cas la
capacité d'agir
euh deux petites données de de cadrage
effectivement sur l'utilisation des
médias le JT de 20h effectivement comme
le disait jean-dianiel Levi reste le
moyen d'information privilégié par les
Français en deuxième vienent internet ça
effectivement par rapport à il y a 20
ans c'était pas le cas on est d'accord
avec les réseaux sociaux les sites
Internet des médias et cetera en 3è
position la presse donc la presse n'est
pas complètement reléguée non plus au
dernier point et en 4e position la la
radio donc il a quand même une une
certaine stabilité et quand on regarde
la confiance détaillée par médias
c'est-à-dire que donc vous avez la
confiance globale est-ce que vous faites
confiance dans les médias non la réponse
est classiquement non mais quand vous
regardez par média et en fonction de des
médias qui sont utilisés par les
Français bah vous vous rendez compte que
les niveaux de cons de confiance sont
beaucoup plus élevé et sont même
majoritaires par exemple quand on dit
bah est-ce que vous faites confiance
vous qui regardez le JT est-ce que vous
faites confiance aux information qui
vous sont donné dans le JT oui oui vous
qui regardez vous qui lisez la presse
quotidienne régionale est-ce que vous
faites confiance à à à à cette presse
quotidienne régionale oui je fais
majoritairement confiance donc c'est ça
aussi c'est effectivement euh le CE
sentimentl et ce paradoxe français
d'avoir une mauvaise image de
l'institution mais finalement dans le
détail et dans la pratique et j'ai envie
de faire une petite comparaison avec les
hommes et les femmes politiques
c'est-à-dire que d'une manière générale
si vous demandez estce que vous avez une
bonne image ou une mauvaise image des
hommes ou des femmes politiques vous
avez des scores assez critiques or si
vous dites mais mais est-ce que vous
vous avez confiance au bonne image de
votre député dans votre circonscription
là les scores euh remontent de façon
assez extraordinaire donc voilà on a
effectivement quand même un un
parallèle assez intéressant à à à noter
et puis enfin peut-être dernier point
sur les réseaux sociaux parce que le
baroban de cette année faisait un point
peu spécifique parce que c'est quand
même aussi de nouveaux usages de
nouvelles habitudes et cetera souvent
décrié euh et en même temps très
valorisé par euh par par les jeunes ils
sont très utilisés mais alors là pour le
coup le niveau de confiance est beaucoup
moins important que les autres médias
comme la télé la presse et la radio y
compris les jeunes les jeunes vont se
différencier sur deux points un ils
considèrent que ces réseaux sociaux leur
permettent d'accéder à une information
et surtout de s'intérê à une actualité à
laquelle il ne s'intéressaient pas
forcément donc ça c'est un point
intéressante et deuxième point par
rapport au reste de la population qui tr
que les informations sont plutôt trop
redondantes et qu'elles sont aussi
qu'elles véhicuent parfois de fausses
informations et diffuse de vos
informations ce qui est pas le cas chez
les jeunes et deuxième point de
différenciation entre la population
générale et les jeunes c'est que la
population générale souhaiterait
davantage de régulation et de contrôle
sur ces réseaux sociaux pour éviter
justement la diffusion de fausses
informations alors que les plus jeunes
sont au contraire beaucoup plus ouvert
et moins enclin à cette
régulation et ce contrôle voilà
peut-être pour terminer ce propos
liimminire
merci beaucoup monsieur cotr je sais que
vous devez nous quitter prochainement
est-ce que vous voulez ajouter deux
trois mots avant que je passe la parole
à nos collègues à mes collègues oui je
veux bien toutes mes excuses de devoir
quitter la la Réunion effectivement dans
dans 35 40 minutes je dois devant mes
mes étudiants mais pour pour rebondir
oui effectivement nous aussi dans nos
données on a une confiance dans les
réseaux sociaux qui est bien bien
inférieur au niveau de confiance de 10
points inférieurs au niveau de confiance
dans ensemble des médias je voudrais
aussi rejoindre plusieurs points qui ont
été qui ont été dit effectivement le
côté profondément anxiogène qui est
ressenti par beaucoup en en voyant et je
dirais que de ce point de vue-là je
pense que on en a même fait les uns et
et les autres
l'expérience même même un drogué de
l'actualité politique comme moi peut à
un moment donné trouver que c'est trop
que c'est trop quoi le sentiment d'être
dans une avalance
permanente de choses traumatisantes
anxiogènes de mauvaises nouvelles de de
de passage en boucle pendant des heures
alors je sais que personne ne nous
oblige évidemment à regarder la télé ou
à écouter les les
informations bien évidemment mais là
c'est c'est le paradoxe total nous nous
regardons des médias nous les écoutons
nous utilisons les réseaux sociaux dans
lesquels nous n'avons pas confiance
voilà mais mais c'est vrai que voilà
cette dimension à la fois d'être
toujours dans les mêmes problèmes
traité de manière
extrêmement
anxiogène il nous il nous arrive aux uns
et aux autres de de de parler avec des
gens qui nous disent moi je peux plus je
peux plus regarder c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est trop quoi donc je pense que
là effectivement il y a il y a il y a un
vrai sujet j'aime bien ce qui a été dit
également à la fois par jean-dianiel
Lévi et l salving sur effectivement un
peu un certain nombre de de de un
certain nombre de de de paradoxe les
gens s'intéressent à l'actualité ité à
la formation politique c'est une très
bonne nouvelle pour nous tous une très
très belle nouvelle je je partage avec
ce que ce qui a été dit l'idée qu'il y a
des des ressorts extrêmement positifs et
intéressants d'apétence civique chez
chez tout le monde c'est simplement les
les les le le système d'information et
parfois aussi le système politique qui
est qui est en difficulté pour aller
chercher euh cette appétence pour aller
la la la valoriser dans l'espace public
mais effectivement il y a beaucoup
d'intérêt pour la chose publique dans
notre dans notre pays c'est une c'est
une très belle nouvelle pour nous tous
ça n'empêche pas que les acteurs de
l'espace public soit perçu de manière
aussi négative sur un point que disait
lors Salvin qui est
effectivement cette drôle de paradoxe où
la confiance en général est mauvaise
mais si on demande aux gens et le JT que
vous venez de de
regarder donc forcément oui bien bien
évidemment c'est c'est si on si on est
devient un habitué d'un journal d'un JT
ou d'une chaîne d'info forcément il il y
a un niveau de de familiarité de
connivance à un moment donné qui qui
s'instore on peut même prendre de
l'attachement pour les personnalités
qu'on voit dans les émissions de dans
les émissions de télé mais je pense
qu'il faut maintenir quand même cette
cette idée de d'éduquer au pluralisme et
à l'idée qu'il faut aller euh multiplier
les sources vérifier les sources
comparer les chaînes et de ce point de
vuelà je voudrais terminer en en
soulignant à nouveau tout l'effort que
tout le monde doit
faire les acteurs du débat public la
représentation nationale que vous êtes
pour miser sur ce long terme d'une
éducation à la à la citoyenneté
pluraliste et
tolérante merci beaucoup donc maintenant
je vais passer la parole à à mes
collègues et pour le groupe Renaissance
Emmanuel Pellerin merci madame la
présidente madame messieurs je tiens
tout d'abord à saluer le travail de mes
collègues violette spbout Jérémy
patrietus et Laurent eskenegex eskenegx
pardon qui sont à l'initiative du groupe
de travail médiia et information
majorité présidentielle où 25 députés
prennent part aux états généraux de
l'information lancé le 3 octobre dernier
les états généraux de l'information ont
pour objectif de poser les bases d'un
modèle espace médiatique et numérique
pour les futures générations en y
associant les professionnels les
chercheurs et les citoyens une
initiative que je salue car il ne s'agit
pas non seulement seulement de protéger
le droit à l'information mais de le
promouvoir dans un cadre mouvant en
proie à de profondes mutations
intelligence artificielle indépendance
des rédactions financement de
l'audiovisuel public concentration des
médias ces états généraux se dérouleront
jusqu'à l'été 2024 et Monsieur Monsieur
Bruno lasser qui les préside a annoncé
que des propositions seront transmises à
la représentation nationale en juin
prochain dans l'attente de ces
propositions je vous remercie pour votre
présence aujourd'hui la perception des
Français l'égard des médias et de
l'information est un sujet crucial pour
comprendre les différentes pratiques des
Français en matière
d'information leur intérêt pour
l'actualité la fatigue informationnelle
l'utilisation des médias ou encore la
méfiance envers ces derniers
en effet 54 % des Français pensent qu'il
faut généralement se méfier des médias
sur les grands sujets d'actualité selon
le baromètre sur la confiance des
Français dans les médias réalisés chaque
année par verriant pour la croix ma
question est la suivante comment
pouvons-nous en tant que représentant
politique et acteurs médiatique répondre
efficacement à la défiance croissance
des citoyens français envers les médias
et quelles actions concrètes
pourrions-nous mettre en œuvre pour
restaurer la confiance dans
l'information merci infiniment merci
monsieur le député pour le rassemblement
national Philippe
Ballard alors Emmanuel voilà merci ouais
c'est bon maintenant merci Madame la la
présidente madame messieurs quand on
s'intéresse à la perception des frant
sur les médias l'information et les
journalistes on s'aperçoit qu'ils sont
plein et vous avez employé le mot madame
salving tout à l'heure c'est le mot que
j'avais écrit mais avant d'écouter nos
trois aateurs plein de paradoxe ils ont
globalement soif d'information mais sont
méfiants envers les médias tout en
faisant confiance aux médias dont ils se
sentent le plus proche et là il y a une
notion d'âge qui rentre en compte on
pourrait ajouter que le regard sur les
journaliste est assez critique alors le
constat si l'on en croit le dernier
baromètre du cvipof les médias arrivent
sur la troisème marche du podium mais du
podium des plus mal classés c'est juste
devant les partis politiques et les
réseaux sociaux comme on dit peut mieux
faire et c'est pas difficile pourtant
les Français sont en quête d'information
et ont une appétence pour l'actualité
mais nouveau PARAD x ils sont et le
chiffre a été cité 57 % a estimé qu'il
faut se méfier de ce que disent les
médias sur les grands sujets c'est le
baromètre pour la croix alors on peut se
dire que la méfiance est généralisée
mais dans la même étude 67 % trouve
fiable et là on en a aussi parlé lesgité
des grandes chaînne les fameux 20eurs et
fiable également la presse écrite et la
radio la population la plus âgée étant
la plus confiante envers ces médias
quant au réseaux sociaux ils sont
considérés comme non fiables par 60 %
des personnes mais un tiers des Français
et plus de la moitié ce qui est
peut-être inquiétant des moins de 35 ans
disent s'informer tous les jours via les
réseaux sociaux là aussi il y a un
nouveau paradoxe alors concernant la
confiance dans les influenceurs là c'est
la bzina personne ne leur fait confiance
et puis autre phénomène qu'on remarque
dans ces différentses études 57 % des
personnes estiment que les journalistes
ne sont pas indépendants alors
indépendants par rapport à qui au
pouvoir politique aux annonceurs aux
actionnaires question face à ce constat
il est indispensable de penser c'est une
réelle politique d'éducation au médias
quelle serait selon vous la meilleure
manière de la concrétiser comme il me
reste une poignée de seconde une petite
remarque sur le côté anxiogène moi
j'aiété jouriste pendant très longtemps
je l'ai toujours entendu depuis 30 35 40
ans donc je pense qu'il y a rien de
nouveau mais j'ai pas de chiffres précis
là-dessus merci beaucoup merci monsieur
le député pour elle et filles Sarah lein
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs pour votre
présence pour vos vos interventions très
très
intéressantes il y a un discours
déplorant la défiance des Français
vis-à-vis des médias qui fait totalement
floresse en ce moment en tant que
législateur on doit se poser la question
des causes et moi ce que je constate et
mon mon collègue du rassemblement
national vient apporter encore une
démonstration c'est que bien souvent on
va chercher les causes en dehors du
système médiatique lui-même un manque
d'éducation des Français un usage abusif
des réseaux sociaux et cetera
jean-dianiel Levi vous venez de dire
qu'il y avait une confiance globale en
fait dans les journalistes qui
souhaitent bien faire impliqués et
sincèr mais qui seraiit limité par les
systèmes dans lesquels ils sont donc
j'aimerais vous interroger sur la façon
dont la nature même du système
médiatique pèse sur la confiance des
Français il semble que la question de la
déontologie est plus que jamais posé à
l'heure où l'éditorialisme moutonnier la
quête de buzz semble supplanter le
travail d'enquête journalistique et de
reportage euh comment est-ce que les
conditions de contrôle ou d'absence de
contrôle des obligations de pluralisme
de représentation de la diversité
parfois tout simplement de respect de la
loi et des lois contre le racisme et
discrimination euh influe sur cette
défiance moi personnellement je suis
frappée par l'écho euh dans les réseaux
sociaux qu'on peut voir des saisines et
des sanctions ou absence de sanction de
LARCOM ou par exemple la critique
récente par le Conseil d'État du refus
de l'arcom de mettre en donneur ces news
ou encore l'écho de notre commission
d'enquête faite par la France insoumise
sur le le contenu et le contrôle les
autorisations de service de télévision
TNT on voit qu'il y a une appétence sur
ce sujet-là autre aspect du système la
question de la concentration de la
propriété des médias entre quelques
mains d'une poigné milliardairire dont
certains comme boreé assument pleinement
une forme d'ingérence 56 % des Français
pens pense que les journalistes ne sont
pas à l'abri des pressions financières
91 français pour des Français disent
important ou essentiel que les médias
préservent leur indépendance vis-à-vis
des des milieux économiques nous on
avait commandé
un
maisant ça marche il faut maintenant ça
marche oui mais en fait non il y a tous
les micros qui sont allumés donc
visiblement il y a un problème oui lui
il marche on m'entend mais visiblement
il y a un problème d'enregistre et de
diffusion donc mais je vous demanderai
aussi chers collègues d'être euh
bienveillant euh notamment avec la
personne du compte-rendu qui ne va pas
pouvoir réécouter si c'est pas
enregistré donc éventuellement si vous
avez vos interventions écrites lui lui
donner pour pour la fin voilà en
attendant que ça que le problème soit
résolu Sophi met pour les démocrates
alors ça doit marcher oui merci madame
la
présidente madame messieurs je vous
remercie pour votre présence à cette
table ronde l'édition 2023 du baromètre
réalisé par cantar public pour la croix
en partenariat avec one point a pointé
un regain d'intérêt pour l'actualité et
une hausse de la confiance accordée aux
médias par les Français interrogés plus
14 points par rapport à
la
donc nous avons toujours le problème de
régie et pour les socialistes apparentés
inak qui et chanise est-ce que ça marche
oui ça marche merci madame la présidente
madame Messieurs chers collègues face au
sentiment de défiance des Français et
des Français envers les médias
j'aimerais vous interroger sur la place
occupée par la presse quotidienne
régional vous en avez parlé dans les
pratiques informationnelles de nos
concitoyens malgré les bouleversements
qui frappent actuement ement la PQR
reste la presse quotidienne la plus lue
en France comme le rappelle Pauline
Amiel et Franck Bousquet dans
l'introduction de l'ouvrage qui lui qui
lui consacre ce sont en effet 3,6
million d'exemplaires qui sont vendus
chaque jour par les 52 titres de la PQR
en 2020 si on rapporte ce chiffre au 1,4
million de la presse quotidienne
nationale payante on mesure bien
l'importance des titres régionaux dans
le paysage médiatique français ils
occupent 7p des 10 premières places dans
le paramarè de la diffusion des
quotidiens de plus une étude de l'Ifop
met il y a presque un an le rôle
essentiel d'intermédiaire que la presse
régionale joue à l'échelle de chacun de
ses territoires en fédérant les Français
selon Jérôme Fourquet directeur du
département Opinion et stratégie
d'entreprise de l'Ifop un Français sur
deux lit la presse quotidienne régionale
là où un média comme TF1 touche un
Français sur 5 alors de la fragmentation
des audiences c'est le dernier pilier
qui fonctionne en matière d'information
que pensez-vous de ce constat notamment
au regarde des tendances pour l'année
2024 que vous auriez pu identifier que
vous avez commencé à nous à nous
présenter les médias locaux sont aussi
un espace de lien entre le politique et
les habitants de nos territoires quand
on sait que la défiance envers les
médias et envers les institutions sont
lié l'enjeu de la préservation de la
presse quotidienne régionale est
cruciale sa disparition qui a à craindre
comp tenu de graves difficultés
économiques auxquelles elle fait face
participerait à l'érosion la confiance
dans les médias quel est votre regard
sur le sujet je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député pour les écologistes
Sophie tal poon merci madame la
Présidente et merci à vous d'être d'être
venu et de nous de nous donner toutes
ces toutes ces informations et éléments
d'analyse oui nous partageons totalement
le fait que le média les médias au cœur
d' du système démocratique il y a pas de
démocratie sans médias et que finalement
si on note des une forme de maladie des
médias on c'est dans un démocratie qui
elle va mal et je crois qu'il faut
jamais décorréler les choses moi j'ai
trois questions la question d'abord
c'est vous la première question c'est
vous disiez finalement que la fatigue
informmationnelle était aussi liée au
sentiment d'impuissance c'est-à-dire que
le lecteur le le le téléspectateur se
sent voyur derrière un écran mais pas
mais pas en capacité d'agir est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il y a y aurait une
appétence pour davantage de de de mise
en valeur de tous les engagements qui
existent aujourd'hui dans notre société
notre société elle est pleine
d'associations qui enfin voilà est-ce
que ce serait pour vous une manière d'
d'intéresser davantage deuxièmement vous
parlez de de de la confiance envers les
journalistes mais pas envers le système
est-ce que vous considérez que pourrait
aller dans le sens d'une plus grande
confiance des Françaises et des Français
le fait de donner des droits aux
journalistes par rapport à leurs
actionnaires notamment moi j'ai porté
une proposition de loi pour se faire
très récemment et troisièmement sur la
concentration on voit bien que si
quelques milliardaires peuvent peuvent
capter un certain nombre de médias c'est
aussi parce qu'il y a peut-être une
difficulté à se financer en terme de
modèle économique les Françaises et les
Français sont-ils prêts à payer
davantage pour une meilleure information
et quel a été l'impact de la suppression
de la redevance
pour pour les Françaises et les Français
est-ce que vraiment ils ont considéré
que c'était une bonne idée ou est-ce que
au regard de pouvoir d'achat ou est-ce
que ils se sont interrogés sur les
conséquences que cela pouvait avoir sur
l'indépendance notamment du service
public merci merci madame la députée
pour le groupe GDR Stéphane pe
oui merci madame la présidente Madame et
Messieurs les représentants des
instituts de sondage alors moi je
démarrerai euh par une référence à Marx
si ça ça vous embête pas trop euh qui
écrivait euh à l'époque ce n'est pas la
conscience qui détermine la vie mais la
vie qui détermine la conscience et il
ajouta le système de pensée de chacun
est conditionné par ses conditions
matérielles d'existence et je me suis
remémoré cette phrase au moment de
l'élection présidentielle ou quand même
pendant toute une période et il se
trouvait qu'à cette époque j'étais amené
à à débattre toutes les semaines sur une
chaîne de télévision
euh beaucoup de médias la majorité
d'entre eux en tout cas audiovisuel ont
essayé de placer la question de
l'immigration et de la sécurité au
premier plan du débat de l'élection
présidentielle considérant que c'était
là et sur ces sujets qu'elle allait se
jouer et la réalité vécue par les
Français ont fait que quelqu soit les
les réponses des uns et des autres et et
la traduction en vote mais que c'est la
question du pouvoir d'achat qui l'a
emporté sur tout tous les autres et en
affirmant ainsi euh ce qui était dit par
beaucoup de médias qui se
voulaient un peu prescriptif dans ce
domaine donc ça c'est plutôt rassurant
mais moi ma ma question va aller dans
dans la continuité de ce que disait
Sophie taayer poant tout tout de suite
c'est c'est c'est au moment où puisque
cette audition se situe dans la
préparation des état généraux
d'information
d'information ne pensez-vous pas au
regard de ce que disent vos sondages et
je je j'ajouterai en plus de tout ce qui
a été indiqué précédemment un chiffre
sur le fait qu'il y aurait qu'un quart
des Français qui considèrent que les
journalistes sont indépendant des
pouvoirs d'argent et
des et des pouvoirs politiques donc un/4
qui qui les considère indépendant ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il est urgent de
revoir la loi de 1886 et les seuils d'
antioncentration euh que ça doit être
une priorité sachant qu'on est très loin
de de ce que notre pays a connu au
lendemain de la de la Libération où
beaucoup de prese quotidiennes
régionales étaient tenus par des
coopératives qui représentaient en leur
sein les différentes tendances des
forces qui avaient contribué à la
libération du pays tout ça a été battu
en brèche par les logiques de
concentration capitalistique donc n
a-t-il pas euh urgence
au regard des enjeux de pluralisme et de
démocratie de revoir la loi de 1886 sur
les la la concentration et d'assurer un
statut aux rédaction qui leur permette
d'avoir plus d'indépendance par rapport
au propriétaires de presse merci
monsieur le député j'ai encore un député
inscrit Christopher Weissberg
oui merci beaucoup moi je suis député
des Français des États-Unis donc
évidemment j'ai en tête ce qui se passe
avec Donald Trump qui un enfant de la
télévision un enfant c'est un il est un
peu vieux pour être un enfant mais enfin
malheureusement c'est le cas parfois
dans son comportement et et qui a pris
un peu le le le le pouvoir d'abord par
les réseaux sociaux et ensuite souvent
parce que les médias d'opinion qui sont
qui sont très puissants aux États-Unis
ont ont aussi construit son son et ont
repris son son idéologie et ses propos
la question que je me pose c'est
évidemment on peut on est obligé
obatoirement on fait le parallèle entre
ce que Rupert Murdock a fait aux
États-Unis avec ce que Boloré est en
train de faire en France je voudrais
savoir si vous avez pu tester peut-être
que vous en avez parlé je je crois avoir
je crois pas avoir entendu cette réponse
mais est-ce que quand Boloré rachète le
JDD est-ce que les Français ont
conscience que la ligne éditoriale de ce
journal
change et par ailleurs est-ce que on
peut apprendre plus généralement de ce
qui s'est passé aux États-Unis pour que
le législateur français puisse éviter
ces ces bulles qui se construisent et
qui ensuite empêch l'esprit critique de
part et d'autre merci merci monsieur le
député Fabienne Colboc
oui merci merci beaucoup pour vos
présentations moi je voudrais savoir
quel est l'angle de la jeunesse enfin
quel angle vous prenez sur la jeunesse
et leur rapport à l'information leur
rapport aux médias quels sont les sujets
qu'ils sont qui les intéresse le plus et
sous sur quel support il s'informe et
comment s'il y a une difficulté les
reconquérir à
l'information merci donc ben je vais
vous laisser déjà répondre à ces
questions il y en aura peut-être
d'autres qui seront suscités par vos
réponses
qui il y a des points sur lesquels je
pense que l'UR sera plus à même de
pouvoir répondre notamment parce qu'elle
a comme elle l'a rappelé la 37e vague
d'une enquête qui permet de suivre des
données de manière un peu longitudinale
euh peut-être en préalable euh rappeler
que euh nous sommes ici des euh des des
sondeurs et nous sommes euh heureusement
ou malheureusement pas des législateurs
donc ça c'est peut-être le le premier
aspect donc il il y a peut-être des des
des points sur lesquels euh je je
répondrai pas pleinement euh aux
questions que vous nous avez posé le
deuxième aspect
euh qui est peut-être une dimension un
peu de de de de philosophie de la
manière dont du rapport qu'on PE avoir
au métier ce n'est pas forcément parce
qu'il y a des données d'opinion ou c'est
pas forcément parce qu'il y a des
attentes de la part des Français qu'il
faut pleinement les satisfaire et qu'il
y a toujours ce jeu entre un responsable
politique et des acteurs politiques qui
pevent avoir des convictions qui sont
pas forcément exactement celles qui sont
exposées spontanément de la part de nos
compatriotes et jouer un jeu
d'interaction en disant on pense que
vous pouvez attendre ça nous en tant que
législateur nous avons une vision qui
est une vision un peu différente et on
acte du désaccord mais voilà
l'engagement que l'on peut prendre et
les raisons pour lesquelles on peut le
faire puis le troisème aspect les 1000
français 2000 français ou plus qu' nous
sommes amenés à interroger dans le cadre
de nos enquêtes ne sont pas des
experts ne sont pas des personnes qui se
posent la question avec jeis tenté dire
autant de de
de d'intention ou d'intensité que ce que
l'on peut faire ici collectivement donc
il y a forcément ce jeu toujours un peu
subti qu'il faut faire comme dans tout
exercice démocratique de ce qui se passe
dans la population française ce qui peut
être leur aspiration puis la réponse
après qui peut être la réponse à
caractère à caractère politique
euh le donc dans ce contexte là
euh ce qui est certain euh c'est que le
travail qui est entrepris aujourd'hui
euh et d'une manière globale concernant
la réflexion dans le cadre des états
généraux de l'information et
euh appréhender positivement de la part
de nos compatriotes euh ce qui est pas
forcément une évidence euh on a vu
d'ailleurs les débats qui avaient
émaillé un peu globalement la mise en
place de cette forme de réflexion
s'agit-il ou pas potentiellement d'un
phénomène de réappropriation de
l'information qui tournerait vers une
information à caractère officiel ça
n'est pas le registre en tout cas qui
éta utilisé de la part des citoyens
lorsqu'on est amené à les interroger sur
les états généraux de de l'information
le le le deuxième point qui a été évoqué
concernant les dimension d'indépendance
et d'éducation aux médias
euh d'un point de vue extérieur ceci
nous apparaît comme étant absolument
primordial on voit bien queil y a un
accès et une digestion entre guillemets
de l'infation qui est assez socialement
marqué et que s'il y a un acteur qui a
la capacité à pouvoir limiter justement
les différences sociales ou les
différences culturel inhérente aux
individus c'est forcément l'école qui
peut jouer ce rôle là et et et qui peut
même jouer un rôle un peu plus global ce
terme a été utilisé dans le rappel de ce
que peut être la démocratie de son
fonctionnement de son de son essence
voire même je le dis ici de sa fragilité
et et que tout ce qui apparaît comme
étant un acquis inv vétéré ne l'est pas
forcément surtout s'il n'a pas fait
l'objet de campagnes informationnelle ou
de campagne d'éducation auprès des
jeunes générations et notamment auprès
des personnes qui évoluent dans des
univers avec des CAP capau culturel qui
va être un petit peu différent ou un peu
moindre que d'autres que d'autres
Français donc la l'idée de de
sensibilisé au principe même
informationnel et indiquer dans quelle
mesure cela peut être amené à faire de
chacun des citoyens nous apparaît comme
étant essentiel et c'est vrai que quand
on travaille sur ce que les uns ou les
autres on peut être amenés à retenir
l'information la manière don ils peuvent
considérer l'information on voit bien
que en complément des variables d'âge il
y a évidemment la variable sociale et la
variable culturelle qui joue euh de
manière extrêmement forte le troisème
aspect
euh est-ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui euh
l'idée qu'il pourrait y avoir
euh
des un système de concentration dans les
médias ou euh d'emprise euh du de
certains médias privé euh de de de ce
que peut être la l'information euh
les enquêtes que l'on mène jusqu'à
présent ne permettent pas de montrer ça
de manière nette c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
en tout cas quand on aborde de manière
globale la différence entre public et
privé il y a une confiance qui est une
confiance un peu plus importante dans
les médias notamment pas dans les médias
audiovisuels publics par rapport au
privés mais sans qu'il a de césure de
manière assez manifeste quoi qu'il en
soit dans un pays comme la
France tout ce qui est gros est
suspect et tout ce qui apparaît comme
aux mains d'acteurs qui ont des intérêts
économiques ou des intérêts financiers
suscite une forme d'appréhension qui est
une forme d'appréhension
négative
vient après une question qui peut être
amenée à sposer dans quelle mesure les
Français arrivent clairement à
identifier déjà d'un point de vue global
ce qui relève d'un média public ou d'un
média privé et aussi surprenamment que
cela puisse paraître la césure qui nous
apparaît ou qui peut nous apparaître ici
collectivement comme étant évidente ne
l'est pas de la part de la totalité des
individus que nous sommes amenés à
interroger et des grandes chaînes de
télévision privées peuvent être perçus
comme étant publ aujourd'hui aux yeux
des individus même si on a eu et si on a
connu des débats notamment au milieu des
années au milieu des années 80 et le
troisème aspect concomitant c'est qu'il
y a pas toujours la connaissance des
actionnaires ou des regroupements
actionnari qui peuvent exister
aujourd'hui dans les médias et les
récentes évolutions ne sont pas toujours
perçu de manière extrêmement précise de
la part des individus et donc ça renvoie
un peu à l'interrogation qui peut être
faite est-ce que lorsque on a un journal
type le Journal du Dimanche qui a une
évolution d'un point de vue éditorial
est-ce que ceci est tout à fait perçu de
la part des des citoyennes et des
citoyens pas tout à fait pas tout à fait
et je vais vous prendre d'R d'autres
exemples nous sommes amenés à travailler
aussi bien sur des magazines municipaux
sur des sur des prises enfin sur sur des
magazines d'intérêt général voire même
sur des grands médias de presse écrite
qui sont et qui passe du temps à
travailler pas forcément déjà d'un point
de vue éditoriel mais d'un point de vue
de maquette leur nouvelle formule avec
un travail qui est un travail
considérable avec des évolutions qui
sont évolutions absolu et que lorsque
nous sommes amenés à effectu des post
test ou des interrogations à postérior
alors même que nous pouvons avoir des
abonnés alors même que nous pouvons
avoir des lecteurs qui sont non
seulement abonnés mais des vrais
lecteurs il y a un effet qui est un
effet terriblement déceptif pour tous
ceux qui ont entamé ce travail de
rénovation de modernisation parce que
souvent cela n'est pas identifié en tout
cas avant même qu'on leur soumette
l'idée que c'est la modification a eu
lieu de la part pourtant d'un public qui
est un public captif et attentif donc
les transformations éditorielles mettent
du temps également à être perçu de la de
la part des individus et puis qui plus
est les habitudes de consommation les
habitudes de lecture que l'on peut avoir
font qu'on va pas forcément ni se
désabonner ni arrêter du jour au
lendemain de lire ou d'écouter ou de de
regarder un journal une radio ou
éventuellement une chaîne de une chaîne
de télévision
euh d'un point sur les autres aspects
qui avaient été qui avaient été évoqués
euh peut-être un un un point qui a peut
été euh qui a peut été souligné enfin
lor av fait référence tout à l'heure
mais l'idée de lutte contre les fake
news apparaît également comme étant une
assignation qui est effectuée à l'égard
des médias aujourd'hui et peut-être un
point distinctif de ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de médias traditionnel par
rapport aux autres types de médias on
revient justement à l'idée qui est une
idée de sincérité à une idée qui est une
idée d'objectivité ou éventuellement à
une idée qui peut être une idée de nous
savons pertinemment préalablement ce que
peut être les opinions des uns et des
autres autres avant même qu'il prennent
la parole et qu'il ne se ne s'abrite pas
derrière un chapeau qui sera un chapeau
d'expertise ou de connaissance alors que
ils ne l'ont pas forcément entièrement
il est fait référence et vous l'avez
évoqué au fait que parfois on peut
retrouver sur les mêmes plateaux les
mêmes personnes avec pour autant des
sujets qui sont des sujets différents
évidemment cela vient renforcer le
sentiment de défiance ou de remise en
cause d'une forme d'expertise on parlait
tout à l'heure de l'absence de confiance
d'un point de vue global qui dépasse le
strict cadre des médias et là en
l'espèce c'est sont-ils vraiment experts
ou à quel titre sont-ils amenés à
prendre la parole et à avoir un avis qui
un jour sur la période de coronavirus
qui sur la guerre en Ukraine qui sur
l'attaque du du Hamas en Israël qui sur
la Coupe du monde de rugby enfin je
prends des exemples qui peuvent être
différents mais qui peuvent amener des
des Français à se dire au bout d'un
moment bah on nous met en avant des
personnes qui sont censées avoir une
forme d'expertise et de connaissance et
pour lequel en fait on a du mal à
pouvoir déjà dissocier ce qui relève du
commentaire de l'analyse voire de
l'information et avec une forme de
sincérité qui pour partie peut être peut
être interrogé
euh vous avez fait référence également à
la PQR euh indémiablement euh le le
niveau de confiance est un niveau de
confiance net aujourd'hui à l'égard de
la PQ même si on voit bien que la
l'information a tendance en tout cas la
consommation de PQ a tendance à baisser
cela renvoie également à un aspect qui
ressort à travers nos enquêtes c'est
aidez-nous parfois à mieux comprendre la
vie du quotidien aidez-nous parfois à
pouvoir trouver des solutions ou à
pouvoir être illustratif et peut-être
pour faire un
parallèle entre la critique qui peut
être émise à l'égard du monde politique
d'un point de vue global j'aime pas
englober en tout cas c'est ce qui
parfois ressort et le monde
journalistique je vais faire la même la
même
généralité absolument terrible c'est
vous ne nous connaissez pas
vous ne nous comprenez pas et donc vous
êtes amené à parler de sujets qui sont
des sujets qui sont déjà ou souvent très
éloignés de nos propres sujets de
préoccupation ou qui vont intéresser un
petit cercle qui va être un petit cercle
fermé mais qui va renvoyer une forme
d'entre soi vous allez vous parler
collectivement au final vous n'allez pas
vous vous adresser à nous et dans une
certaine mesure la PQR en tout cas la
résistance qui existe aujourd'hui la p
de la PC à l'égard de la baisse de la
consommation d'information pour partie
par écrit s'inscrit justement dans un
registre qui est un registre où en fait
on renvoie ou au moins on parle de nous
et on arrive à savoir que nos sujets de
préoccupation sont des sujets qui
peuvent être relayés dans les dans les
médias peut-être pour pas monopoliser la
parole un aspect qui est un aspect
extrêmement sensible c'est la question
de payer pour avoir de
l'information nous avons avons des
générations qui n'ont pas été
culturellement exposées au fait qu'il
fallait payer pour avoir de
l'information
euh je on émet des doutes sur le fait
qu'on va pouvoir vraiment les amener à
se dire que maintenant il va falloir
mensuellement ou annuellement débourser
une somme qui au regard d'autrre types
de somme peut apparaître comme étant
modeste pour avoir une information
qui aujourd'hui peuvent leur apparaître
comme étant facilement accessibles et
qui plus un s'inscrit dans une démarche
qui est une démarche différente de par
le passé c'est qu'on va plus toujours
chercher l'information mais
l'information vient à soi et que le
développement de ce que peut être les
plateformes de ce que peut être
les les réseaux sociaux voire même les
différentes notifications que l'on peut
avoir sans même toujours les avoir
sollicité ou sans même s'être inscrit à
tel ou tel site fait que le registre et
le recours à l'idée de se dire qu'on va
non seulement chercher l'information
mais payer pour cela je dis pas qu'elle
fait pas sens pour les jeunes
générations mais en tout cas elle fait
quand même beaucoup moins sens que pour
ceux qui ont été euh collectivement euh
on va dire socialisé dans les années 70
80 voire années voire années 90 donc
c'est évidemment un enjeu ça va pas
forcément dire que l'enjeu n'est pas
accessible on voit bien que euh par le
passé en tout cas au début des années
2000 voire même jusqu'au milieu des
années 2000 la quasi totalité des
articles en ligne était gratuit que ça
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui donc il y
a des petites modifications qui s'opère
mais ça touche encore des générations
qui avaient par le passé l'habitude de
d'aller au kiosque ou d'avoir des
abonnements et ce qui n'est pas
forcément celle qui est culturellement
partagée de la part des des plus jeunes
des plus jeunes générations
[Musique]
euh peut-être le dernier point le
dernier point euh sur
l'idée en fait que l'on
a aujourd'hui une jeunesse qui serait
une jeunesse
désinformée c'est pas tout à fait le
sentiment que l'on a elle elle a entendu
parler de beaucoup de
choses mais pour autant le rapport à
l'information est un peu moins d'aller
creuser de manière systématique donc ils
entendent parler des choses est-ce que
pour autant il peuvent développer plus
que cela ce que peut être les contenus
informationnels pas toujours donc il y a
une exposition qui reste une exposition
nette avec peut-être un fond qui peut
être un fond un peu moins important de
la part des jeunes générations par
rapport aux générations qui sont des
générations un peu plus un peu plus
anciennes merci Madame salving euh alors
peut-être quelques compléments euh du
coup effectivement d'abord sur sur la
PCR euh effectivement c'est
euh le deuxè média en qui on a le plus
confiance par rapport euh aux autres
médias euh en premier ce sont les
journaux télévisés d'information et donc
en 2uxe c'est la presse régionale
qu'elle soit quotidienne ou hebdomadaire
donc effectivement vous avez plus de 60
% 61 % des Français qui disent faire
confiance aux informations qui sont
données euh dans la presse régionale
effectivement c'est c'est quelque chose
d'assez constant depuis de nombreuses de
nombreuses années pourquoi les Français
nous disent bah déjà parce qu'en fait on
peut vérifier l'information c'est-à-dire
que même si on va pas la vérifier
systématiquement il suffit que on passe
devant un pont pour bien voir
effectivement qu'il est en travaux ou
pour entendre parler de l'ouverture de
tel ou tel euh
enseigne par exemple donc il y a il y a
cette idée de
effectivement vérification possible et
puis comme le disait Jean-Daniel Levi de
proximité en fait euh et on le voit
d'ailleurs dans dans nos données
d'enquête ce que nous disent les
Français c'est on ne parle pas assez des
tracas du quotidien des difficultés que
les Français rencontrent avec notamment
les services publics et quelles sont les
revendications aujourd'hui pour faire un
lien avec l'actualité des des
agriculteurs notamment c'est de dire
simplifiez-nous la vie on a trop euh de
travail administratif trop de de de bah
de tracas administratif justement pour
pouvoir bien bien mener à à à bien notre
notre travail donc cette question de
voilà vérification contrôle et puis euh
quotidienneté euh et ancrage
effectivement dans les préoccupations
euh des des
Français un deuxème point peut-être sur
sur les jeunes euh les jeunes
effectivement alors ils se il ils se
caractérisent euh par une confiance plus
accrue à l'égard des réseaux des réseaux
sociaux mais sur le reste en fait ils
sont assez comparables au reste de la de
la population ce qui euh ce qui est
marquant aussi chez eux c'est la
capacité de décrochage c'est-à-dire que
euh ben ils zappent d'une information à
l'autre et effectivement comme disait
jean-dianiel levvy ils en ont entendu
parler ils vont pas forcément creuser ce
qu'ils nous disent aussi c'est que euh
ils ne comprennent pas forcément ce
qu'on veut leur dire il y a et là c'est
là où je pense qu'il y a une une comment
dire une nécessité de la part à la fois
des journalistes mais aussi des acteurs
public de simplifier leurs propos et de
bien faire attention à qui ils
s'adressent et quel type de langage
aussi il ils utilisent euh on avait fait
une étude il y a quelques années de cela
pour le ministère de l'Économie pour
savoir si les Français comprenaient les
mots qui étaient utilisés d'une manière
générale en é économie dans les médias
ne serait-ce que PIB
inflation et cetera et cetera croissance
décroissance et les résultats avaient
été atterants effectivement on se
rendait compte que les Français
n'avaient qu'une idée très partielle de
ce que la cela
pouvait représenter et c'est pour ça que
je pense qu'il y a un décalage aussi
entre ce que les Français ben
comprennent réellement des sujets
parfois un peu techniques les sujets
d'économie sont parfois un peu
techniques et ce que les journalistes
considèrent eux que les Français peuvent
peuvent entendre et je rejoins à nouveau
jean-diel quand il disait les Français
nous disent en fait vous nous connaissez
pas et vous nous comprenez pas mais en
fait je rajouterai nous ne vous
comprenons pas non plus en fait c'est ça
c'est c'est c'est ça le
problème sur la gratuité effectivement
dans ben la dernière édition de du
baromètre la croix nous avons posé une
question là-dessus et donc là à nouveau
les jeunes se
se singularise he effectivement c'est
vraiment la génération de la gratuité de
l'accès à l'information comme finalement
un besoin c'est ça revient à un besoin
prioritaire de première nécessité en
fait si vous voulez donc ça doit être
accessible très facilement est-ce que
vous seriez prêt donc là que ce soit
jeune ou ou plus âgés à souscrire un
abonnement un média pour accéder à un
contenu payant pour avoir une meilleure
information de qualité c'est non à 67 %
est-ce que vous pourriez payer de
manière ponctuelle non à 67 % faire un
don régulier pour soutenir un média et
améliorer la qualité de l'information
non à 64 % voilà bref effectivement la
question de la gratuité en tout cas est
pas encore
dans dans les esprits et puis je pense
qu'il y a un débat aussi qu'on n pas
réussi à à faire passer et ça pour le
coup c'est une tendance lourde dans
l'opinion depuis de nombreuses années
sur l'indépendance des journalistes vous
demandierz par rapport à quoi les
Français considèrent que les les
journalistes ne sont pas indépendants
voez dans dans dans dans les questions
qu'on peut poser 59 % des Français
aujourd'hui nous disent qu'ils ne sont
pas indépendants aux pression des partis
politiques et du pouvoir et je crois que
ça rejoint un peu une des thématiques
que pierre-cles a souhaité traiter à de
nombreuses reprises il y a de nombreuses
années donc c'est c'est toujours le même
sujet dans dans son film pas vu pas pris
notamment mais l'idée effectivement de
collusion de de connivance et d'un petit
monde
journalisticopitique ou
politico-journalistique effectivement
euh qu'on n' pas réussi à à contredire
et ça je crois qu'effectivement ça
rejoint un peu le
euh les perceptions des Français sur
l'idée qu'il y a une élite en France
versus le reste de la population et que
les deux ne se parlent pas ne se
comprennent pas et ne s'intéressent pas
forcément les uns les uns aux autres sur
la partie publ privé effectivement
systématiquement les médias publics sont
quand même notés de façon plus positive
que les médias privé notamment en terme
de pluralité d'opinion et de diversité
en terme également d'innovation et de
renouvellement ça je trouve ça
intéressant pour
le le secteur public parce que
finalement les Français ne considèrent
pas que l'innovation et le
renouvellement ne viennent que par le
privé ça peut aussi être une volonté de
l'État et une volonté des des politiques
du coup
de de de de de de favoriser ce genre de
de choses dans les médias pr public
pardon et puis l'indépendance des
rédactions également 45 % considèrent
effectivement que l'existence de médias
audiovisuel publ est une bonne chose
pour cette indépendance là seulement 26
% pour les les groupes de presse privés
donc effectivement il y a une une une
une différence entre les deux et enfin
pour conclure peut-être euh on parlait
d'éducation à à l'information euh
éducation des Français je pense qu'il y
a aussi une question euh de formation
des journalistes certainement notamment
sur effectivement euh
comment comment bien comprendre les
besoins en terme d'information des
Français
euh s'ajuster en terme de discours aussi
quand cela est est nécessaire euh nous
sondeurs nous sommes très décriés en
période électorale notamment quand nous
produisons des intentions de de vote qui
ne sont pas des prédictions mais bien
des intentions de votes qui sont donc de
l'opinion on a proposer à plusieurs
reprises à des journalistes de venir euh
chez nous regarder comment ça se passe
regarder comment on produit ses
intentions de vote on leur a proposé
également de leur vraiment ouvrir nos
dossiers pour les former on n' pas
réussi à monter un seul une seule
session de formation aux journalistes
donc voilà je crois que
effectivement il y a beaucoup de choses
que les Français doivent
apprendre que les Français doivent
entendre mais il y a aussi certainement
peut-être une remise en cause que les
que les journalistes devraient aussi
peut-être s'appliquer euh et notamment
euh euh sur sur ces sujets-là dernier
point peut-être sur la lutte contre les
désinformation parce qu'on a mené des
expérimentations euh notamment en
Angleterre et en France qui me semble
assez intéressante on a remarqué que
finalement ce qui permettait le plus de
lutter contre la
désinformation c'était de euh envoyer
des messages régulièrement aux citoyens
leur disant attention il il y a une
possibilité d'in de de d'information
erronée ou en tout cas attention ce type
d'information là existe c'est pas tant
de décrer telle ou telle information
fausse mais c'est plutôt de d'habituer
les Français à l'idée qu'il peut y en
avoir et ça effectivement on a vu
qu'ensuite quand on quand on regardait
le le le niveau de confiance à l'égard
d'information ça pouvait faire bouger
les choses au niveau des des perceptions
donc voilà alerter juste sur le fait que
ça existe c'est déjà un moyen de lutter
contre la
désinformation merci beaucoup est-ce que
certains collègues veulent reposer une
question oui parce que moi j'en aurai
une aussi après non non non non mais
euh alors là V c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon oui non c'est vraiment merci
beaucoup pour pour ces retours toujours
très très
intéressants plusieurs plusieurs aspects
me demander si vous aviez des éléments
sur la façon dont les Français
percevaient spécifiquement les
conditions de travail des journalistes
plus précisément les statut des
journalistes vous avez parlé de cette
défiance vis-à-vis d'une sorte de caste
journalistique qui serait un entre soi
déconnecté de la vie des Français quelle
perception les Français ont-ils de la
différence peut-être entre les
éitorialistes qu'il voi occuper un grand
nombre de plateaux passer d'un plateau à
l'autre parler comme vous vous l'avez
très bien dit de sujets dont on se
demande en quoi ils ont une expertise
dessus et les journalistes qui font du
travail d'enquête de terrain qui sont
parfois exposés à la à des formes de
précarité de de de rythme de travail
parfois aussi du coup à des formes de
pression quelle quelle perception il y a
de cette sociologie journalistique et
par ailleurs pensez-vous ne pensez-vous
pas que sur cette histoire d'impression
d'entre soois journalistique il n y
aurait pas quand même des mesures à
prendre de nature à minima de
transparence voire de certaines
réglementation déotologiqu quand on
découvre que la ministre la plus en
cause en ce moment Amélie
casterra a une partie des membres de sa
famille qui occupe très très largement
l'espace médiatique en la qualité de
journaliste ou de ou d'éditorialiste ou
quand vous avez quelqu'un comme Anna
Cabana qui avec des étoiles dans les
yeux parle du président Macron ou même
de Jean-Michel Blanquer dont elle est
l'épouse ou ce genre de de phénomène qui
je pense nuisent profondément à l'image
que qu'on peut avoir d'un journalisme
indépendant et qui ne serait pas là pour
relayer la parole des puissants euh et
euh et des et des des dominants d'une
certaine façon donc qu'est-ce que on
pourrait préconiser comme règle pour que
au moins ça se sache vous avez aussi
évoquer le fait que les Français
n'étaient pas forcément au courant des
des intérêts économiques et des
conditions économiques donc est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à des règles de
transparence sur qui détient les médias
et des transparences sur les liens qu'il
y a entre entre la sphère politique la
sphère économique et la sphère
médiatique et puis des règles peut-être
qui euh qui obligeraient à des formes de
de déport et qui seraient des règles euh
à à faire respecté d'une façon ou d'une
autre par la puissance publique merci
merci
oui oui merci bon je vais pas vous
demander les solutions juste juste
puisque
euh nous on a des propositions mais cela
dit et je crois qu'on les partage mais
juste une question parce que vous vous
avez de méthodes vous avez parlé
beaucoup et dissocié les réseaux sociaux
la presse écrite et cetera qui sont des
façons de réfléchir he qu'on qu'on a
depuis longtemps des cadres de réflexion
qu'on a depuis longtemps mais qui sont
en train quand même de s'effacer puisque
personnellement moi je lis la presse
écrite sur internet je regarde la
télévision sur les réseaux sociaux et
cetera et cetera donc comment est-ce
qu'on peut continuer à avoir une analyse
un
peu je dirais bah construite et qui
permet de réfléchir quand on voit quand
même que le le le type de médiia se
brouille et que tous les supports
finalement convergent euh ou en tout cas
utilise enfin tous les supports
utilisent tous les supports ou en tout
cas tous les supports utilisent internet
et les réseaux sociaux
merci donc moi j'avais deux questions à
à vous
poser parce que Madame Salvin vous avez
parler de l'information comme une comme
une nécessité pour pour les jeunes comme
si c'était un voilà un bien au même
titre que l'air
l'eau et donc je voulais savoir en fait
quelle était cette perception est-ce que
l'info c'est un bien comme un autre ou
pas et est-ce qu'il y a un un besoin
d'information parce qu'on a parlé de
fatigue informationnelle mais finalement
on peut aussi le retourner à ce qu'il y
a un besoin d'information et puis une
autre question
euh
qui qui me qui m'est venue c'est sur
est-ce que les citoyens et citoyennes
perçoivent bien la différence de statut
entre un journaliste et un animateur ou
un influenceur en fait est-ce qu'il y a
toujours cette compréhension facilité de
savoir qui parle d'où on parle et est-ce
que ce serait pas de nature justement à
restaurer un lien de confiance parce que
l'on voit bien et même on voit aussi
qu'entre collègues quand nous nous
exprimons nous allons
chercher les les exemples qui vont
confirmer ce que nous sommes en train de
dire et pas forcément avec toujours la
toute la pluralité qu'il faudrait donc
c'est c'est alors je ne sais pas si
c'est normal mais bon c'est c'est
souvent le cas donc est-ce que le fait
de bien
indiquer d'où on parle et et qui parle
est-ce que ce serait de nature sur selon
vous à pouvoir restaurer le sentiment de
confiance ou d'instaurer d'ailleurs
puisque vous nous avez dit que c'est
tout au long enfin sur les dernières
années il y avait finalement peu de
changement donc on augmenté ce ce
sentiment merci peut-être je je réagis
tout suite sur sur plusieurs dimensions
je pense qu'effectivement les études
d'opinion le montte il y a un vrai
besoin d'information il y a un vrai
intérêt c'est ce qu'on disait au départ
euh à l'égard de ce qui se passe autour
de autour de soi et y compris même un
niveau plus global au niveau national
c'est le cas aussi des des jeunes les
jeunes ne disent pas qu'ils se
désintéressent à l'actualité pas du
tout ils disent au contraire justement
que les réseaux sociaux leur permettent
de s'y intéresser davantage avec leurs
méthodes alors évidemment chez les
jeunes gocrypt comme vous connaissez
fait fait fait un Taba et devient
vraiment une référence donc donc et puis
il y a quand même une tradition aussi du
JT effectivement qui reste encore ancrée
dans un certain nombre
de de de famille et donc comment dire un
certain respect aussi pour des choses
traditionnelles y compris y compris chez
les jeunes sur la la sociologie des
journalistes je pense qu'effectivement
il y a un vrai sujet parce que vous
voyez bien que quand déjà on on demande
au français s'ils ont une confiance
générale à l'égard des institutions on
voit que les résultats sont bien moins
élevé que quand on déjà détaille média
par média et puis effectivement si on
demandait quelles images j'avais de d'un
présentateur télé comme vous dites ou
deun journaliste de terrain et cetera je
pense que à nouveau il y aurait de de
j'ai pas de données chiffrées mais il y
aurait évidemment des des différences
extrêmement fortes et ce qu'on a
remarqué effectivement dans dans ce
dernier baromètre notamment sur
l'intelligence artificiel les Français
ne sont pas du tout euh euh réticents à
l'utilisation de de l'intelligence
artificielle dans les médias notamment
peut-être pour choisir des des contenus
qui vont être poussés pour aider les
journalistes à réfléchir sur des sujets
et cetera dans la mesure où on est
transparent avec eux et qu'on leur
indique effectivement euh voilà sujet
générés par l'intelligence artificielle
euh de la même façon par exemple pour
des traduction traduction générée par de
de l'intelligence artificielle et cetera
donc je pense que vous avez vous avez
raison sur sur ce point plus on on
donnera au aux Français à la population
française des billes pour bien
comprendre et analyser ce qu'il voi dans
les médias et plus effectivement on
nourrira ce lien de de confiance où
effectivement sans sans le rétablir
parce que finalement c'est n jamais été
là mais en tout cas pour essayer de de
commencer justement à à à construire une
relation de confiance h
merci
h est-ce que les Français connaissent
les conditions de travail des
journalistes la réponse est non est-ce
qu'il non est-ce qu'ils savent
précisément ce que peut être les
contraintes éditoriales les contraintes
de temps les contraintes de la
vérification des sources euh le le les
enfin les différents enjeux qui peuvent
exister au sein des rédactions pas
vraiment
euh pas vraiment et qui plusit en tout
cas j'ai pas eu l'impression à travers
différentes enquêtes qu'on a pu être
amené à R que c un sujet qui les
passionnait ou qui les intéressait
euh il apparaît encore aujourd'hui comme
étant un métier plutôt prestigieux ENF
en tout cas d'un point de vue global que
globalement bah ils ont choisi de le
faire et donc bah s'ils ont choisi de le
faire il se débrouille pour pouvoir le
faire et sans que aujourd'hui les
conditions d'exercice de l'activité
professionnelle soit devenu un enjeu qui
est un enjeu manifeste dans la
population française ça veut pas dire
que si jamais il devait être confronté à
ce que sont les injonctions forcément
les injonctions contradictoires les
difficultés les conditions de production
d'information qui sont aujourd'hui
presque paradoxalement même parfois plus
difficiles que ce qui pour exister il y
a encore il y a encore quelques années
il ne changeraiit pas d'avis ou il
s'intéresseraiit un peu pas unu plus à
ça mais enfin aujourd'hui c'est plus
entre guillemets la question du produit
fini que la question des conditions de
réalisation qui qui marqu et ce qu'a dit
ce qu'a dit Laur est extrêmement
intéressant le fait qu'il y a pas
forcément de rétisence absolue à la
question de l'intelligence artificielle
ou que globalement quand on est
l'information qui arrive par un pouche X
ou Y et qu'on se demande pas d'où ça
vient comment ça a été fait et cetera ça
montre bien que ben on prend
l'information comme étant une dimension
un peu un peu propre le le deuxième
aspect
euh arrive-t-il ou pas à faire la
différence déjà aujourd'hui entre
éditorialiste et journaliste voire
présentateur pas toujours mais peut-être
que nous même dans cette salle on peut
parfois être un peu déstabilisé parce
qu'on peut voir sur certaines chaînes
d'information et que le présentateur
peut devenir un expert en fonction d'é
missission et puis
redevenir personne qui est en charge de
la distribution de la parole donc on a
même dans l'exposition réelle
aujourd'hui une répartition des rôles et
qui est très claire au regard de la
construction de chacune des cesmions et
mais qui n pas forcément en fait aux
yeux des aux yeux des individus la
dimension influenceur on arrive quand
même un peu plus à voir les choses et
puis d'utant plus que c'est présent sur
un réseau qui est un réseau enfin sur
des réseau qui sont des réseaux un peu
un peu particuliers euh vous avez raison
je pense de dire que peut-être que la
césure en tout cas que la que le côté
séparation entre réseau sociaux d'un
côté internet de l'autre et médiia
traditionnel de l'autre médiia
traditionnel est
peut-être exagéré par rapport à la
réalité de la
consommation en gros c'est vrai dans un
sens c'est pas tout à fait vrai dans
l'autre c'està-dire qu'aujourd'hui quand
on est exposé à une source d'information
un peu traditionnelle si on entr surme
là il y a peu d'insertion en fait de ce
que peut être les réseaux sociaux sur
ces dans ces médias traditionnels là
tandis qu'à l'inverse quand on est
présent et quand on va se confronter à
l'information à travers les réseaux
sociaux évidemment on va avoir de la
presse écrite traditionnelle on va avoir
la télévision on va avoir différents
extraits qui peuvent sortir de de de de
différents types de médias euh mais
autant là encore dans les années 70 80
voir 90 la socialisation autour du type
de
médias jouait un rôle dans
l'appropriation de l'information autant
aujourd'hui quand on interroge les
français et notamment les jeunes
générations où avez-vous entendu cette
information ou sur quel type de médiia
ou qui était à l'émission de
l'information le label d'origine même
s'il est un label de qualité est quand
même aujourd'hui un peu moins
identifi et si on do caricaturer est-ce
qu'on a vu cette information sur un
journal de gauche ou un journal de
droite ou éventuellement on s'entend sur
les termes ou éventuellement relayé par
les réseaux sociaux le le le la question
de la tonalité de la coloration initiale
est quand même beaucoup moins vu de la
part des Françaises et des Français et
encore beaucoup moins identifié de la
part des jeunes générations encore une
fois parce que culturellement elles
n'ont pas été construites comme ça elles
n'ont pas vu en fait les affrontements
entre différents éditoriauxx qui
pouvaient paraître et qui apparaissait
comme étant profondément ancré de
manière de manière différente euh de
peut-être deux derniers points
euh euh l l'a
évoqué il y a parfois la perception
d'avoir une forme de cast
politico-journalistique
parisienne et avec même parfois le
reproche qui est fait à des responsables
politiques mais qui par
euh par effet touche également les
journalistes c'est on a parfois
l'impression que vous ne cherchez pas à
nous convaincre nous téléspectateurs
mais vous cherchez à convaincre le
journaliste qui est à côté de vous et
vous cherchez à convaincre le
journaliste avec qui en dehors
éventuellement des faits euh qui peut
être des des dimensions à caractère euh
familial de toute proximité euh font que
globalement vous évoluez dans le même
univers et même par rapport à ce
qu'indiiqué lors tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que vous parlez de sujets
qui vous intéressent collectivement nous
ça va pas forcément être amené à nous
toucher euh et au final c'est pas euh
moi derrière mon téléviseur qui doit
être convaincu mais c'est à partir du
moment où avez le sentiment vous avez
les sentiment des journalistes
formidable très bien et vous vous
semblez satisfait d'avoir atteint votre
votre but
euh le le le le dernier point dernier
point concernant euh la différence entre
journaliste de terrain et journaliste de
plateau oui elle est évidente elle est
évidente euh et la la différence qui a
été soulignée d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
par par l'or entre l'image de la PQR et
les autres types de support voir la
presse quotidienne nationale montre bien
il y a encore une différence qui est
effectuée et même de la part des jeunes
générations euh je dis pas que Hugo
descrypt fait du travail de terrain mais
il donne le sentiment d'être euh au
contact vraiment des préoccupations de
la part des individus euh on on a eu euh
on a même à l'heure actuelle
l'émergence de commentaires en direct de
prise de parole de la part de
responsable politique de la de de de
décrypteurs voir euh de euh de de
personnes qui sont présentes sur twitch
ou autres et qui vont faire que le la
personne qui va regarder ne va même pas
forcément entendre la totalité du propos
de la part du responsable politique mais
il va déjà entendre de la part du
commentaire voir du déccriptage qui va
être effectué en direct donc c'est même
pas à postérior mais c'est en direct et
quand ça a cru au cours de ces dernières
de ces dernières années au moment des
vœux présidentiels on a vu on l'
identifié qu'il y avait des jeunes qui
avaient regardé Emmanuel Macron en
direct mais pas Emmanuel Macron mais qui
ont vuem uel Macron commenté par
quelqu'un qui disait tout de suite
exactement ce qui se passait
pratiquement comme dans une forme de
match de foot et que même la conférence
de presse avait également amener une
autre forme de consommation de médias où
presque le la confrontation directe ne
va pas exister mais on va avoir une
confrontation qui va être une
confrontation indirecte avec une
personne qui tout de suite va dire ah
bah tiens il a ditici pour ça ou je vous
mets en avant ça ou je vais donner ce
document ou je vais faire ce lien et
cetera qui en gros
enrichi s'agit-il ou pas d'une d'une
d'une disqualification de l'information
d'une disqualification des médias
traditionnels peut-être s'agit-il ou pas
d'une manière de pouvoir aller peut-être
plus au fond et de remettre en cause la
question de la suspicion peut-être
également et que ça montre bien en fait
qu'il y a voilà des nouvelles modalités
d'information qui existent encore une
fois qui restent des informations
gratuites accessibles à tous et sans
qu'on a le sentiment qu'on a besoin de
débourser pour avoir pour satisfaire ou
assouvir son besoin d'information
merci beaucoup merci à tous les
collègues de leur participation merci à
vous deux enfin et à vous trois puisque
nous avions monsieur cotress en en visio
en au début pour toutes ces données et
c'est les réponses aux questions que que
nous avions nous ne manquerons pas de de
revenir vers vous si nous en avons
encore puisqueeffectivement comme je le
disais dans dans mon propos la
commission des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation a voulu prendre toute sa
toute sa place et toute sa part dans
dans ces états généraux de l'information
il nous a paraît vraiment indispensable
de de pouvoir en effet comprendre ce qui
se passe et puis de voir si de façon
législative quel est la place qui sera
la nôtre merci encore